la expresidenta de jeanine áñez
permanece en la cárcel de miraflores no
ha sido evacuada a ningún centro de
salud pues como escuchábamos al ministro
de gobierno las autoridades consideran
que sus lesiones son leves sin embargo
la fuerza especial de lucha contra el
crimen ha calificado el hecho como
tentativa de suicidio y sus abogados
también han señalado que la expresidenta
trata de dar un mensaje de pedido de
auxilio con este hecho que ha sucedido
esta madrugada en la cárcel por otro
lado los líderes opositores han
reaccionado indignados culpando al
gobierno de luis arse por lo que le
pueda suceder a la ex presidenta la
última semana la ex mandataria ha sido
sacada en tres ocasiones de la cárcel de
miraflores para ser llevada a centros de
salud públicos pues se le estaban
practicando diversos análisis agnès
tiene un diagnóstico de hipertensión y
también de depresión y su hija considera
que este diagnóstico pues se está
poniendo en riesgo su vida mary
cuéntenos en qué va el proceso en contra
de la expresidenta ayer sé en cargos de
genocidio contra años que sigue
así es la expresidenta tiene dos tipos
de procesos uno
uno de esos procesos es un proceso
ordinario por el que ella está presa y
la justicia determinado que debe estar
seis meses en detención preventiva sin
embargo esa prisión ha sido ampliada
otros seis meses más por lo tanto ya
nine años permanecería en la cárcel al
menos hasta febrero del próximo año y
por otro lado la fiscalía general ha
presentado una proposición acusatoria
para seguirle un juicio de
responsabilidades por presunto genocidio
por los hechos sucedidos el año 2019
luego de que el grupo de expertos de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos
estableciera que tanto en sacaba como en
senkata se produjeron masacres de
ciudadanos bolivianos
responsabilizando a la expresidenta áñez
y también a las fuerzas de seguridad de
la época medieval acá nuestra
corresponsal en bolivia con los últimos
detalles sobre el estado de salud de la
ex presidenta interina